welcome back the crisis at our southern
border becoming more
dire every day as biden's dhs is now
requesting
thousands of national guard troops stay
on the border past september
as department of homeland security
secretary alejandro mayorkas admits the
surge of migrants
is bigger than it has been in two
decades
he had a message for migrants earlier
today watch
do not come now
give us the time to rebuild the system
that was entirely dismantled in the
prior administration
and we have in fact begun to rebuild
that system
we reinstituted the central american
miners program
that provides a legal and safe way for
children to make their claims here in
the united states
under the law under the laws that were
passed unanimously by congress many
years ago
joining me right now is newt gingrich
he's former speaker of the house and fox
news contributor his news special
the age of rush is available on fox
nation
right now it is a must see and newt it
is wonderful to see you tonight
thanks for being here your reaction to
what you just heard from secretary
marcus well
first of all let me say i thought your
interview with president trump
was very effective and very informative
i commend you for
getting as many different topics as you
did and i think there's no place
where you see a bigger difference
between trump's policy and biden
than on the border president trump
understood
that there are an unmanageable number of
people
who are willing to come the united
states gallup reported a few years back
that there at least 65 million people
who'd like to move to the united states
and president trump recognized
it's just unmanageable president biden
living in some kind of fantasy land
thought he could campaign for open
borders and is now
shocked to discover that in many
countries
the biden open border policy is
interpreted to mean
open borders so we had people i just saw
a republican congressman yesterday
who talked about people from turkey uh
people from
morocco people from china people from
africa i mean that it's not just people
coming out of central america
but the words out you know the the
democrats want to give you free medical
care
they want to take care of you they'll
let you in the country and think about
this difference
if you and i try to fly into the united
states
we have to have a test to prove we don't
have covet
they're just walking across the border
they get tested
i think nine percent have covert in the
last thing i saw
they leave they get on a bus they go
somewhere in america
carrying covet yeah this is a policy of
utter madness it's very disturbing also
the fact that you know when we're
talking about
these issues this is about illegal
immigration i mean you know
my grandfather came here in 1903. he
did it the way you're supposed to do it
my grandparents came earlier than that
they did it legally but this is about
people
getting and cutting the line this
country nationalizes one million people
a year
so i mean obviously america is a
generous country
with open arms but there's a structure
and a way to do it
let me get your take on this agenda and
what the democrats are trying to do
newt i mean nancy pelosi pushing hr1
what is the intent here what is your
take on that as well as this agenda in
general
higher taxes massive spending uh
getting us back into the iran deal the
china meeting in
a couple of days your take
well first of all i think what you're
seeing is a machine
when you win as many narrow votes as
nancy pelosi's winning
when you have the discipline that chuck
schumer has this is a machine
and this machine knows that in a fair
open election
it's going to get killed they're
adopting policies
that have 15 percent approval you take
her entire
corrupt politician re-election act h.r
one and that'll be a more accurate title
for it
uh when you go out and ask the american
people i just saw a poll in
arizona for example every single
provision
is a 75 percent negative now
the two senators from arizona have a
real choice do they vote with the people
of arizona
or are they part of the machine and i
think you're seeing this across the
board
this is a desperate effort to impose
radicalism on america
before they lose the house and probably
lose the senate
in 2022. what about what's going on in
california right now the recall of
governor newsom he's blaming you for the
recall
here's a clip watch this me the
principal
sponsor of this recall effort wants to
put microchips
in immigrant aliens we have folks that
are literally
part of the three percent militia group
right-wing
group that are part of the principal
proponents of
this effort the rnc is the second
largest donor to this effort
the huck pack mike huckabee newt
gingrich is out there devin nunes
uh trump mega donors have put in close
to three million dollars
in this effort it's not his performance
newt it's you and mike huckabee
look the thing that's amazing right now
with president trump
not available to be the number one
pinata target
both on new york and in california
democratic governors are collapsing
and it's going to be fascinating to
watch yeah
newt it's great to talk with you as
always thanks so much